hi there steve kaufman here today and
today i want to talk about
what is the hardest language to learn
now if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe you can click on the bell in
order to get notifications
uh what's the hardest language to learn
first of all before i start you may
notice there's some gaps in my library
i've been going through
culling some of the books that i no
longer want to keep around so i've
donated three boxes of books
to uh local thrift store anyway that's
why it looks a bit messy back there
uh the hardest language to learn
you know i think that's a very difficult
question because there are so many
factors that enter into that
um you know what you want to do with the
language
uh do you want to pass a test
do you want to just enjoy the language
do you want to enjoy movies books in the
language
do you want to just be able to
communicate in the language and
different languages are
you know they have different degrees of
difficulty depending on what you want to
achieve
but i would say that
the biggest factor in determining how
difficult a language is for you
is how motivated you are to learn that
language
if you find your motivation
flagging
if you find that you don't like the
language
that's going to make that language very
difficult to learn
if on the other hand you love the
language you want to lang they'll learn
the language you either you have a
friend or a loved one or a relative or
you enjoy aspects of the culture and
you're very motivated that language will
be easier to learn because any
objective difficulties
only make the language more interesting
so you'll be you know pushing yourself
to overcome these difficulties so the
number one consideration in my mind is
you know
your relationship to the language
the second thing is
how easy is it to find content of
interest content that's
comprehensible maybe but potentially
even if it's not yet comprehensible if
it's attractive to you and this is very
subjective so here again some people are
attracted by say anime for japanese
which doesn't appeal to me at all
it can be anything i happen to be
attracted to history so
uh and and right now i'm very interested
in this sort of central asia
uh iran you know turkish arabic even
just finished reading a book about
genghis khan
and the mongols and the amazing impact
that they had on history both in a
negative and a positive way and so
those kinds of things that that
you know make it uh you know in terms of
something you can sink your teeth into
literature history music whatever that's
got to be there
uh where you can't find that then it's
more difficult and this can depend this
can vary from you know time to time you
may
be trying to learn a language and not
finding anything of interest and then
later on because you meet a friend or
because you discover a movie or
something all of a sudden
that interest then you know you're
you're fired up again to learn the
language
and that's why
it's so useful
now that in addition to whatever
you know beginner content you use
you know asi mill or teach yourself or
many stories of link
uh that that then you move on to
things that you can find on the internet
and which you can bring in to link for
example whether it be of you know from
youtube or or or ebooks which i have
often used
or
you know netflix
uh you have to
you know make it you know
make yourself
put yourself in a position where you can
access things that might really
you know turn your crank and there's
this expression expression in french la
petite yeah
give yourself a chance to get carried
away by the language don't go in with
too many prejudices
saying this language is no good i don't
like the sound of the language i find it
boring get in there start to discover
things and pretty soon you may find that
you know you will get attracted uh by it
you know i'm i'm now going after persian
and arabic and turkish which i wasn't
particularly interested in before and
i'm very interested in so that element
of motivation is very important
of course
you know if we look at objective
considerations
um
the more the language is similar to a
language you know
the easier it's going to be
the more the vocabulary is similar
particularly the vocabulary so that you
don't have to struggle to remember words
and i always say that the number of
words you know
your the size of your vocabulary will
determine your ability to understand if
you can understand well you'll
eventually learn to speak well
uh or at least to communicate
so
how similar the language is to a
language you already know is a big
factor
this can have pluses and minuses now i'm
finding for example in portuguese that i
know spanish
therefore portuguese
uh
from one perspective is easier because
the vocabulary is like more than 90 the
same and the grammatical structure is
more than 90 the same
but because they're so similar it's
difficult to totally throw myself into
sort of a portuguese environment the
spanish
control center in my brain is kind of
holding on and preventing me from
you know
totally starting afresh in this other
language on the other hand if i go into
arabic or persian there is no other
language that is influencing my persian
or arabic so to some degree
that is a
difficulty with languages that are very
similar but that's a minor consideration
overwhelmingly the more similar the
languages are
the easier it's going to be to learn
them another consideration of course is
writing system
i've grown up reading using the latin
alphabet so even though i can read
the cyrillic alphabet i can read chinese
characters hangul khanna
even greek
arabic with some difficulty
you know it's so difficult i find to get
used to comfortably reading in another
script
it's one thing to decipher it figure out
this is these are the symbols this is
what they you know the sounds that they
represent but to actually get to where
you can just comfortably read in another
script i find that's a big step
like for me polish and czech are much
easier than russian and ukrainian
because it's so much easier for me
there's no resistance when i read in the
latin alphabet whereas reading in
cyrillic even though i have read so much
in cyrillic it's just that little bit
more difficult so
it's always a challenge and when i learn
another a language with another script i
put a lot of effort into just just
making sure i spent enough time reading
in that script because that's going to
improve my comprehension and that's why
i for the time being i put turkish on
the back burner and i'm focusing on
persian and arabic in order to get my
brain more and more used to reading in
this other script and i know from
experience that everything in language
learning including reading in another
script is just a question of time
and enough exposure so that your brain
will gradually develop new habits but
the emphasis is on gradually and slowly
there's no instant eureka so a different
writing system obviously
is an element of difficulty in
particular a writing system like chinese
characters where it's not phonetic it's
not a matter of learning a finite number
of symbols
20 30 40 50 symbols you have to learn
thousands of pictograms so that makes
chinese more difficult i've said before
that there is a compensation because so
many of what we would
term words in english are combinations
of these pictograms so once you have
them you can then easily more easily
remember new words that are combinations
of these characters that you have
already learned but still it does make
it more difficult pronunciation can be
an issue
uh but to me that's also a question of
time
and
you know the solution to many of these
difficulties is simply exposing yourself
to the language listening enough
getting the intonation of the language
speaking without
feeling self-conscious about it
uh and of course grammar i find that uh
you know objectively speaking
chinese and even japanese and korean
grammar
are
less complicated there are fewer little
bits of you know detail that you can
easily get wrong than say in
russian slavic languages german and so
forth so the more
detail there are in the language the
more things that change like case
endings change or conjugations the verb
endings change the more of these things
that are
not so much a question of logic of the
language but i mean there is that logic
but
a logic that is hidden behind a bunch of
rules and tables
the more of these things you have in a
language the more difficult it is
especially to speak correctly now
if your objective is to understand the
language to be able to communicate
connect with people
as is the case with me in most of my
languages i'm not tremendously concerned
about how accurately i speak of course i
want to speak more accurately
but but i can't speak accurately in all
of these languages that i'm learning
uh
i want to speak more accurately if i
make a video in arabic and i you know i
i say uh that i you know yukta kalam
instead of atakalam like you've got to
change the beginning the suffix
depending on the person and stuff like
that and i get it wrong some of the time
right sometimes
and i hear that i notice it and and
slowly hopefully i improve
but it doesn't uh in any way detract
from my enjoyment of the language
on the other hand if your goal if you're
working
in arabic or you know russian or
whatever and you're
putting out business correspondence or
you're at formal meetings and there's
obviously a or you're going to write a
test then there is a greater need to be
accurate
so difficulty in terms of understanding
it is one thing difficulty in terms of
being able to read it and listen to it
and enjoy movies is one thing difficulty
in terms of being accurate and creating
a very positive impression because you
are essentially making very few mistakes
that's another level of difficulty i
think honestly uh you know in french
some people find french difficult to
understand because of the the way the
words flow into each other with the sort
of liaison
uh
but another big obstacle in french is
the gender gender is
the is more obvious in spanish
uh you know most words that end in all
are masculine and most words that end in
a are feminine spanish very
straightforward italian french not so
and when i listen to our canadian
politicians
uh english-speaking politicians who
speak french and some of them speak
quite well and yet the gender is the
thing that trips them up because
it's not something that we have in
english
it's very difficult to develop new
habits new grammatical habits it doesn't
prevent them from communicating
and similarly with people learning
english i often mention that we have a
colleague russian who
speaks absolutely perfect english there
isn't anything he can't express or
explain in in english and yet to him the
articles remain a problem because
obviously it's not something that is
part of the sort of language habits of
russian speakers or for that matter of
speakers of many other languages that
don't have articles
there are languages with no articles
languages with no gender languages with
no
with
no singular plural
um
yeah uh languages uh have different uh
different ways of expressing essentially
the same thoughts
and we have to get used to them and some
of them are a little harder to you know
develop these new habits than
in others
so there you have it so i don't want to
say that any particular language is
harder to learn but i rather wanted to
set out what i think are some of the
factors that determine how difficult a
language may be for you